الاتحاد التونسي العام للشغل اكبر مظله
نقابيه وعماليه في البلاد واقدم الهيئات
المدنيه فيها وكان له على الدوام حضور
سياسي فاعل لا يستهان به قوته تاتي من نحو
700 الف منتسب ينتشرون في ارجاء تونس كافه
ويمثلون نحو سته في المئه من عدد سكانها
و13% من مجموع من يحق لهم التصويت في
الانتخابات
للاتحاد العام التونسي للشغل دور لافت في
محطات تاريخيه مهمه في تاريخ تونس منها ما
عرف باحداث الخميس الاسود في السادس
والعشرين من يناير عام
1978 حين خرج الاف النقابيين من مختلف
القطاعات احتجاجا على الاوضاع والسياسات
الاقتصاديه سبقها وصاحبها اضراب عام دعا
اليه الاتحاد حينها اطلقت قوات الامن
والجيش النار على المحتجين ما ادى الى
مقتل واصابه المئات منهم واعتقالي وتعذيبي
مئات اخرين
شاركت قواعد في الاحتجاجات التي شهدتها
تونس في الاول من يناير عام
1984 والتي عرفت باحداث الخبز بعد قرار
الحكومه رفع الدعم عن الحبوب والارتفاع
الحادي باسعار الخبز الاحتجاجات استمرت
رغم قمعها بقوه واعلان السلطات حاله
الطوارئ وحظر التجوال ولم تنتهي الا في
السادس من يناير حين اعلن الرئيس انذاك
الحبيب بوركيبا التراجع عن اجراءات
الحكومه في الثوره التونسيه التي اندلعت
في الرابع عشر من يناير 2011 كان لقواعد
الاتحاد وفروعه الجهويات دور مع باقي
القوات في دعمها والمشاركه بها وصولا الى
نجاحها في اطاحه نظام زين العابدين بن علي
بعد دخول البلاد حاله من التازم السياسي
الحادث اغتيال السياسي اليساري والنائب في
المجلس التاسيسي محمد الابراهيمي في يوليو
2013 شارك الاتحاد التونسي للشغل فيما عرف
برباعيه الحوار الوطني لانقاذ عمليه
الانتقال السياسي في البلاد وبعد مفاوضات
شاقه وطويله نجحت الرباعيه في نزع فتيل
الانفجار بعد ان شهد تونس في يناير 2014
التصديق على دستور جديد وتشكيل حكومه
مستقله الامر الذي مكن الاتحاد مع باقي
اعضاء الرباعيه من الفوز لاحقا بجائزه
نوبل للسلام